contundente de rechazo internacional por
parte de la unión europea eeuu y varios
países latinoamericanos a las elecciones
parlamentarias en venezuela donde la
abstención se sitúa por encima del 70% y
el chavismo llegó nuevamente al poder
legislativo tenemos reportes de
washington y bruselas
continúan estancadas las conversaciones
entre la unión europea y reino unido-
para la relación post cracks y de los
líderes británicos y el bloque
comunitario no lograron reducir las
diferencias por lo que la presidenta de
la comisión europea y el primer ministro
británico acordaron reunirse de forma
presencial en bruselas
las elecciones generales de ghana se
celebraron hoy sin incidentes y con una
alta participación
el presidente saliente nana akufo-addo
opta por un segundo mandato de cuatro
años se trata de las octavas elecciones
consecutivas desde la restauración de la
democracia en 1992 en ghana una de las
más estables de áfrica tenemos reportes
con nuestro enviado especial
muy buenas noches gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france24 sierra blanca
un gusto saludarlos comenzamos a este
informativo en venezuela donde crece en
el número de países que rechazan los
resultados de las elecciones
legislativas celebradas este domingo ya
son casi 50 las naciones que no
reconocen el triunfo del chavismo en
américa el bloque más grande que ha
dicho hasta el momento de desconocer el
resultado de la votación lo constituyen
16 países que van desde canadá pasando
por el salvador guatemala guyana haití
honduras y panamá paraguay perú
república dominicana colombia ecuador
costa rica y chile en eeuu el secretario
de estado- maicon feo pidió a sus
aliados que sigan reconociendo como
presidente interino a juan guaidó y por
su parte la unión europea pidió la
celebración de un venezuela de
elecciones transparentes desde bruselas
y desde washington nuestros
corresponsales nos dieron los detalles
tal y como se esperaba la unión europea
no reconoce el resultado de las
elecciones legislativas en venezuela los
cancilleres europeos han constatado que
los comicios no fueron ni creíbles ni
transparentes y que carecen de toda
legitimidad ya que en gran parte la
oposición no formó parte de ellos así
que ahora mismo la unión europea tiene
la vista puesta en la fecha del 5 de
enero día en que se disuelve la asamblea
nacional dirigida por juan guaidó el
jefe de la diplomacia europea se ocurre
ya avanzado que hablará con el grupo
internacional de contacto formada por
países europeos también con países de la
región como argentina y ecuador para
abordar qué tipo de futuro le espera al
país si se puede encontrar realmente una
solución política al conflicto actual
así como hablar también del papel futuro
que se le se reserva a partir de ahora a
juan guaidó que está reconocido como
presidente encargado por más de 60
países
el secretario de estado mike pompeo dijo
que el régimen ilegítimo de maduro en
venezuela montó una farsa electoral que
pretende hacer pasar por elecciones
legislativas en el comunicado con pero
dice que condena esta parodia que no
cumplió con los más mínimos estándares
de credibilidad además agrega que casi
60 países y organizaciones de todo el
mundo incluidos eeuu la unión europea en
la organización de estados américanos el
grupo de lima y el grupo de contacto
internacional rechazan este simulacro
electoral
washington ya había afirmado que seguirá
reconociendo a juan guaidó como
presidente interino y elliot abrams
enviado especial para ese país resaltó
que además se vendrán sanciones para los
responsables del fraude electoral por su
parte yo bailé en presidente electo
también se ha manifestado en el pasado
diciendo que es hora de pasar la página
del régimen de nicolás maduro
las conversaciones entre la unión
europea y reino unido- continúan
bloqueadas la presidenta de la comisión
europea úrsula von der layen y el primer
ministro británico boris johnson
acordaron durante una conversación
telefónica reunirse de forma presencial
en bruselas para así abordar la
negociación sobre la relación comercial
futura tras el divorcio veamos el
informe
mientras el reloj avanza en los últimos
intentos de llegar a un acuerdo
comercial post break ship el último
obstáculo podría ser uno que domina las
conversaciones desde el principio las
reglas de juego equitativas el problema
está en el corazón del break sheet la
parte británica insiste en la soberanía
mientras que bruselas dice que la
competencia abierta y justa es
primordial reinounido abandona el
mercado único de la unión europea y la
unión aduanera a fin de año durante
meses los negociadores han intentado
acordar cómo funcionará el comercio
entre las dos partes después de esa
fecha para ello se discute un conjunto
de reglas y estándares que garantizan
que las empresas de un país no tengan
ventaja competitiva sobre las de otro la
unión europea quiere que estas reglas se
apliquen a toda regulación sobre
derechos laborales medioambiente
impuestos y ayudas estatales
bruselas insiste en que reino unido no
puede tener el mejor acceso al mercado
único si se aparta de estas regulaciones
dando a las empresas británicas ventajas
comerciales sobre sus rivales europeos
la unión europea es el mayor socio
comercial del reino unido- el año pasado
las exportaciones británicas
de la unión europea fueron de 325 mil
millones de euros 43% de las
exportaciones totales las importaciones
del reino unido- de la unión europea
fueron de 414 mil millones de euros 52
por ciento de todas las importaciones
británicas boris johnson quiere decidir
las reglas y las regulaciones de reino
unido pero también quiere un acuerdo sin
aranceles ni cuotas ha criticado a la
unión europea por no ofrecer un acuerdo
comercial similar al que tiene con
canadá pero bruselas dice que reino
unido debe estar sujeto a las reglas más
estrictas como una de las economías más
grandes del mundo y una que ya está
estrechamente vinculada a los mercados
europeos
cambiamos ahora de información pero
seguimos en reino unido donde las
autoridades empiezan mañana su programa
de vacunación contra el cob y 19 el
mayor de su historia después de
convertirse la semana pasada en el
primer país del mundo en aprobar el uso
de la vacuna de facer y para jon tec el
ministro de sanidad mat hancock confirmó
que todas las regiones del territorio
británico han recibido ya una parte
proporcional de las 800.000 dosis
iniciales que se ofrecerán en esta
primera fase a los grupos más
vulnerables de la población comenzando
por los mayores de 80 años
continuamos en europa el ex presidente
francés nicolas sarkozy testificó este
lunes ante el tribunal que le juzga por
corrupción y tráfico de influencias
delitos que negó de forma tajante al
tiempo que atacó a la fiscalidad
nacional financiera a la que acusó de
tejer contra él una persecución desde su
salida del icio durante más de tres
horas el hombre que dirigió francia
entre 2007 y 2012 desestimó las
acusaciones sacadas a la luz tras las
conversaciones mantenidas con su abogado
thierry herzog a través de un teléfono
intervenido por la policía en otra
investigación de la financiación libia
de su compañía electoral
cambiamos ahora nuevamente información y
de continente las urnas cerraron en las
elecciones presidenciales de ghana luego
que los ciudadanos votaron en lo que se
espera sea una contienda reñida entre el
presidente nana akufo addo y su
principal rival john mahatma los ojos
están puestos en la potencia de áfrica
occidental para ver si puede mantener su
posición como bastión de la democracia
en la región inestable donde las
disputas electorales de este año han
avivado los temores de un retroceso
hacia el autoritarismo nuestra enviada
especial marian cone con los detalles
se esperaba que casi 17 millones de
personas votarán hoy por el momento la
participación no ha sido comunicada por
la comisión electoral de ghana durante
todo el día los votantes fueron acogidos
en estricto cumplimiento de las cocinas
debidas a la epidemia de coronavirus
llevarse más cara a lavarse las manos y
el distanciamiento social estaban a la
orden del día la votación de hoy será
claramente entre dos políticos nana
akufo addo y jon mamá que han estado
compartir el poder desde el 2012
la votación promete ser muy cerrada
aunque las encuestas dan dan a
akufo-addo como el gran ganador en
general las elecciones se desarrollan
sin problemas hay sólo un accidente
grave en el este del país en la ciudad
de casos donde personas no identificadas
abrieron fuego contra el coche de un
ministro y la de la oposición hirieron a
cuatro personas entre ellas un
periodista
así las cosas en ghana hablemos ahora de
cultura bob dylan leyenda de la música
rock y premio nobel de literatura vendió
los derechos de todo su catálogo musical
que engloba más de 60 años hay universal
music
este acuerdo incluye más de 600
canciones del músico y los medios de
comunicación en eeuu señalan que su
repertorio podría estar valorado en al
menos 300 millones de dólares
y con música es pedimos este informativo
continúa con nosotros muy buena noche